give a token we'll be talking about
arrival of random walks Thank You Daniel
a yes I'm very happy to give this talk
this is brand-new slide for the first
time I'm not recycling any slide so I'm
very excited myself also I think the
result is quite interesting so this is a
joint work with Kunta boo at least for
the mahi and Bahamas a sort of ski so
what is it about it might be a bit
cryptic like this so it's a worst case
for a viscous reduction from the ideal
short vector problem to itself and we do
this by considering the space of whole
idea lattices and this is called the
Oracle of classical so it might resonate
a little bit with a few things that had
happened this week where we were talking
about the space of all lattices SLN over
over a salon of Z and basically Oracle
of class group is equivalent of this
space for ideal lattices so what is
exactly the result so the Hermit is VP
problem so first I'm not doing exactly
the shortest vector problem I'm doing
the Hermit variant of it so this means
that I'm not asking you to find a vector
who a short vector who'll actively - the
shortest vector but more in an absolute
sense more relatively to the volume of
the lattice and instead of having the
hood Hammad volume the hood volume in
the equation a simpler way of doing this
is just assume that the volume of my
lattice is 1 and this is going to be
particularly nice in the setup of Africa
loves you so ok you're given a lattice
it has volume 1 and you have to find a
vector of length shorter than gamma and
our main result is that if you can do
that over a random ideal lattices in a
particular ring let's say I don't want
to go too much into number theory I'm
aware that you're just out of lunch
and also I was asked to really go easy
on you
I promise I'll do that but Benjamin
would so you can do this for Honda my
dear lettuces you can also do it for any
ideal lettuce over the same ring and on
the way you are losing a little bit on
the approximation factor but actually
not that much making the extended
Riemann hypothesis and some of my life
policies you can get this loss factor to
about square root of n okay
so before I go into the details how does
it relate to to the literature well
actually there is you know when we
started working on a result with oh this
is the first time in the lattice world
where we had use well schedule a
wreckage of the same problem because
some time you reduce jingle we2 ideal as
vdeo but this time this was this was the
same column I did as VB to idea and we
thought we were the first but no Daniel
told us also really Oh 10 years ago Jen
here what you did it but it's okay so
how does that result differ it defers
mostly in the way we define a condom so
gently kind of defined as a I doc condom
distribution for her for his condom case
I mean it's not bad for category it's
actually a security solution you can
sample form so it could build an effigy
out of this distribution but
mathematically it's maybe a bit
frustrating as a distribution we also
hitch you know stronger reduction in
terms of tightness and we also don't
need a factor in Oracle to make it work
what's more interesting about this
result is that it relates to recent
development in crypt analysis over ideal
lattices those are the same tools that
have been used by Adam nastily and
analyst Perry Meridian their quarters
when they were working on the the crypt
analysis of ideal lattices maybe with
some some more Hawkinson so basically
the lattice they constructed this
morning you can relate it to a lattice
of relation over hockey love class group
so I cannot
group was actually hidden inside his
talk and I'm gonna make it a bit more
explicit join mine
and the last point that I find
particularly interesting is that the
strategy for the poof is exactly the
same as a strategy that we've already
seen in the world of elliptic curve
based category so somehow there was this
result of Yahoo Miller and Venkatesh and
where they proved that the discrete
logarithm problem was essentially as
hard in every elliptic curve was
essentially as out in elliptic curve of
ISO journey graph I certainly in an
illusion Agathe that in any of those
also scale so again I was told not to go
too hard on the number series so I'm
gonna play a little game of table so
here my five forbidden world's number
fell down Amba dingus Galois exact
sequencer and class group no I accepted
to place the reference okay so I'm still
going to need to define some you know
object so others
so what are these are just discreet
rings and to get started I'm just going
to work with Hill quadratic others with
the principle ideal domain property
what does it mean well that means that
the class group is trivial thank you
okay so basically I mean that one of my
forbidden world is useless in this talk
good so what do they look like by a real
quadratic I mean that they I are
embedded into r2 so I want to construct
a ring that is discrete inside r2 all
right and when I say up to I mean are to
not just as a vector space but r2 as a
ring where I have component wise
addition and component wise
multiplication so I mean if I have a
ring I mean free it has to be a freezie
module so I first need to put Z into it
and I really don't have a choice for one
I really have to map one to the
coordinate one one otherwise you know it
has to be it has to be a unit so it
needs to act as the unit on both axes
otherwise it's going to collapse to one
dimensional thing and then I need to
choose a second point that make into a
lattice but also a ring and that's where
you need a number of theoretical magic
so I'm not going to tell you how it is
done but you're going to have to trust
me that in this particular example is
not only your lattice which is also an
order you might if you know number
theory you immediately recognize it
okay so now that I have another how do i
construct an ideal well I'm just going
to multiply that order by an element
from the space so I choose an alpha you
know the embedding space it's all in the
ambient space
and I'm going to multiply each point of
my order by this alpha and I'm gonna get
an idea
so I cannot always do this but here I
can do it because I assume the PID
property so this case is a bit boring I
just choose alpha equal 1 so my lattice
is exactly the other but then of course
I can buy it and I get many different
ideal lattices all right so if you
remember the first thing I did in this
talk was to assume that the volume was 1
and here I just constructed a lattice
for which the volume is not 100 it's
different from the original volume so
the first thing I can do is scale it
back and when I do this I essentially
constrain myself to choose alphas that
lives on a hyperbola so the hyperbolic
would also go down but if I just
multiply everything by minus 1 I can
make sure that it is on the upper side
of my plane and then I can play with my
alpha but only on this hyperbola and
still get many different ideal lattices
and up to scaling I get them all
let's press essentially means that I do
get all ideal lattices but I just have
to rescale them I work modulo a scaling
I won't work modulo something else so I
want to work modulo lattice that just
looks alike you know they're not exactly
the same but in terms of geometry all
the lengths and all the angles are going
to be the same so essentially I'm going
to call them the same and I'm going to
say that you know there's a symmetric
group and they're equivalent and those
is symmetrical so basically I can forget
about the left part of my hyperbola and
only focus on the right path so now to
define an ideal lattices all I have to
do is to choose an alpha on the right
segment of this hyperbola so it means in
some sense that I have parameterised the
space of all ideal lattices bye-bye
hyperbola and the hyperbola can
parameterize by a single ruler
this parametrization for example so now
it means that yeah really an ideal at
this is just given by a single Hill
number that I'm going to call it and by
modifying this te I get all the the
ideals associated with this order but
the thing is that it is not necessarily
the case that all the hill is defined
different ideal lattices and in fact
after a while if I move T I get the same
ideal lattice again and this is periodic
if I keep increasing it I'm going to
fall cyclically again on it again and
again so what I'm telling you is that
essentially if I want to parameterize
the space of all ideal lattices I don't
even need the full line I just need a
segment and really this segment is kind
of closed on itself okay so it's just a
circle the timing is not perfect I need
to work somewhere in it so what did I
tell you I just told you that the space
of all ID lattices may be modulo those
symmetries that we don't really care
about is just a circle yes for real
quadratic orders so to be yes real
quadratic in pages class number one so
this is something we summarize them up
identically by saying that the auricle
of is isomorphic to the torus of
dimension one and this holds for all the
other Tarheel quadratic and have the
principle ideal property so the little
so peak stands for pika-pika group and
the zero on top means that i'm working
modulo not her normalization okay so
because people take logarithms and stuff
one translate to degree zero whatever
number Siri
yes the elephant is the pig zero thingy
okay so what I just told you is for real
quadratic pids and I told you so those
are orders that I can whose ambient
spaces or to and for those the the
pickle group is just a circle or a
choice of dimension one so what happens
if I remove this assumption let's remove
the quadratic assumption so now my order
lives inside our to the arm and in that
case the pickle group is going to be a
torus of dimension R minus 1 why am I
losing one dimension well that's because
of this key normalization pockets right
so I get a torus as my peak a loop now
I'm gonna remove the Gila sunshine and
now it means that my order is lives
inside R to the ark times C to the C and
in which case it's the peak a loop is
still going to be a tourist but a
slightly bigger one does dimension t to
the R plus C minus one so if you're
thinking in terms of real dimension you
might have the feeling that I've stolen
a few dimension all of you right because
this space on top has dimension at R
plus two C but the thing on the bottom
is just dimension R plus C minus one
the thing is that those dimension that
have been lost have been lost to the
symmetry group because when I put
complex dimension I kind of you know I
have a unit a unit circle on each
complex dimension that I can play
symmetry with so that's why I lose all
those dimensions now let's remove the
PID one and that's where things get ugly
because then the torus get multiplied by
the mmm-hmm and we get a lot of we get
we get a bunch of off to lose instead of
a single one so I should mention here
that my direct product is only as you
know only in the topological sense in
the group
it's not okay so why all this well
because that's I want to think of a
reduction in this set I want to relate
ideal lettuces to each other by thinking
of how do I move to one idealities to
another in this set and that's how I'm
going to get a worse case to average
case reduction so I start from the worst
case ideal lattice and my little little
reduction here is gonna randomly walk on
the come on
thank you it's gonna honda me walk over
the over speaker group to each another
lattice and we're gonna call this layer
audiologists an average case letters
okay and then once is when the reduction
is her she asked for a short vector
please and our reductions are french as
family in France sorry I said she was a
reduction the reduction is getting a
short vector V in this average case
lattice and then the reduction is going
to bring it back little by little to the
worst case lattice by unwalled Kings the
original path but at each step you might
notice that the vector V gets a little
bigger
and in some sense you don't want to make
too long of a walk
the longer the walk the biggest you're
going to lose on the approximation
factor okay and when she's back on the
worst case you say yeah this is your
short vector all right what does it
exactly mean to walk on this thing well
they're actually two ways of walking and
the first way of walking is very
continuous we've already kind of seen it
so I've parameterize my ideal lattices
by a circle and I can just move on the
circle which means I continuously
transform my ideal lattice to another
one and here I call my SVP Oracle I get
a short vector of a certain radius
inside a certain ball and then I walk
back and by walking back I'm distorting
the space and it means that the vector
that originally lived in a ball and now
lives in a ellipsoid that is kind of
distorted so that's why it it can get
bigger it does not get bigger but in the
worst case it does get bigger that's
just one way of working on the pker hoop
and if you just work in this way just
the the the torus is just way too big
you're just going to distort way too
much on your way back and you're going
to get to use less production but there
is another way of walking and this time
instead of doing distortion I'm going to
do specification what does that mean
well there is kind of a way of
teleporting myself from an ideal lattice
to another one that is kind of related
by just removing some of the points in
that lattice okay so come on yes so here
I'm gonna remove one point out of two in
such a way that the new ideal the new
lattice is still an ideal lattice so you
need to be careful how to do this not
all specification verify this but it and
then I get another related lattice but
you might notice that this one is not
exactly on the pickle group because I've
specified it so it's volume is not one
so I need to scale it back okay and now
I'm on the pickle group I can call my
the Oracle and what do I do with a
solution in that sphere well I want to
get back to my original lattice so I
need to undo the scaling and then I just
teleport back to the original point by
undoing the specification so here again
I've kind of increased the size of the
vectors that I got when when I undo this
this renormalization step okay so I have
two ways of walking and now one is kind
of discrete because there's not
infinitely many ways of specifying a
lattice even if you choose if you choose
a fixed index then there is only
finitely many ways of specifying and for
ideal lattices you have even more
constraint you cannot specify with any
index but by combining those we are
still going to be able to reach all
points in the auricle of mm-hmm
and so you should think of specification
as just being discrete jump and I start
from a point and form that I can reach
you know finitely many other points but
they're kind of randomly distributed
over this continuous object and because
I'm only reaching a discrete set inside
a continuous thing I'm not reaching
everything so the specification is nice
because it gets you pretty much
everywhere for very little loss but at
the same time you're really not reaching
everything because you know you're
discrete in a continuous set and then
there is the other kind of step
distortion steps and those one are the
more the continuous walk that we've just
seen and when you're doing this well
you're kind of blurring those dots and
the hope is that by having enough dots
and by blurring them enough you finally
reach the uniform distribution
thank you very much for your attention I
want to give a great thanks to three
blue one nine so maybe you've seen these
videos on the internet and that's he
made this the tool that you used to do
those his videos open-source and that's
how I did my slides it's a lot of fun it
takes way too much time thank you very
much
[Applause]
any question before Benjamin drops in is
most of my question is most of the
question are going to be answered by him
I guess so the only one who can answer
because I'm not playing to boot I'm I'm
gonna say class groups I have the right
to see class groups and I'm going to
abuse that right
so I'm going to give the mathematical of
that side of things so I'm not going to
talk about the worst case for average
case reduction but I'm going to talk
about the the random walks how do you
actually do the random walks and how do
we prove that they do converge to
something that's uniformly distributed
I'm going to start with a simple case
the case of class groups which were deal
which were treated maybe fifteen years
ago by a John Miller and then kept
ascend and we use very similar
techniques so I'm going to walk you
through this kind of simplest setting so
let's fix notations as we start with a
classic web serie number field K of
degree n with ring of integers
oh it's class group is simply the
quotient of these two groups so the
group of fractional ideals in the ring
of integers so by this a group of
principle ideals something very
remarkable is that it's a finite group
the arackliffe as groups wouldn't be
fine groups have you've already noted so
this makes the setting a little bit
simpler mr. Fixx notations ideals are
often going to be written like with
these kinds of letters the norm of the
ideal is n of a and the class of the
ideal in the class group is written with
square brackets so to do random walks in
these finite groups we're going to use
Cayley graphs so what are kilograms
they are graphs where the vertices are
the elements of your group so you can
define Cayley graphs for arbitrary
groups but here I'm just going to work
with fine groups we get finite graphs
and more precisely class groups so here
every red dot represents an element in
the class group alpha is one of these
elements now I can pick an element in
this group or a representative for
itself or for these elements I'm going
to use ideals as representative for
ideal classes so choose an ideal L now
you can use this ideal L to multiply the
elements in your class group can take
this class alpha multiply it by the
class of L you get another element in
the class group which is the class of
the all times alpha and you add an edge
to your graph when you do that so you
add an edge from alpha to L times
I can do this from everywhere can keep
going from there and you go to L square
times alpha I keep going and at some
point you come back to where you started
here you come back to where you started
after three steps which simply
translates to the fact that the ideal L
has order three in the class group okay
we can do this from anywhere in the
graph so in particular you can also do
this on this on these points you didn't
reach and get another cycle which is of
the same length now this is with one I
do L you can pick another one say H and
do the same thing so you go from alpha
to H times our fun at some point you go
back to the origin here after two steps
so H has order 2 and you do this with
every points this is a kala graph so the
vertices are elements in your group and
you've chosen a set s of ideals I'm
going to call that the generating sets
and you add edges to your graph that
corresponds you're multiplying by these
elements in s this is also a labeled
graph because you have well you have the
green arrows which correspond to
multiplication by L and the yellow by H
okay I'm going to talk doing the second
half of the presentation how things
change when you consider the full
arackliffe group if that's your question
[Music]
well I guess it's more difficult because
this specification step will most likely
transform principle things into non
principle things so when you do your
specification you are restricted to
specifications that preserve
principality and that might be yeah yeah
okay so to do random walks we just
follow random edges in this graph so you
start at some ideal class alpha it's
hard to compete with the previous
presentation but I do have little
animations so from alpha you just pick
at random an element in you're
generating sets so here it will be
either L or H so pick one at random and
you follow it so from now if I go to H
times alpha just random from H times
alpha maybe you go to L times H times
alpha etcetera and you do as many steps
as you want and the question you're
asking is after making sufficiently many
steps do you end up uniformly
distributed in there so how fast do you
become uniformly distributed so how do
we choose these generating sets as I
said okay pick two ideals H and L in
general you're going to pick more than
two what you want is these ideals to
have small algebraic norm because the
algebraic norm of the ideals are going
to use will affect the loss of
approximation factor in your reduction
so you want ideal of small norm to do so
you just fix a bound B and you consider
the generating set as B to be the set of
all prime ideals of norm at most B so
these are going to be our generating
sets primary rules of bounded norm now
the question is how large must be B for
the graph to be well connected for
random walks to randomized fast so first
how much how large must be be for the
graph to be even connected if it's not
connected you're not going to have
random walks that become uniform because
you're always going to be stuck in a
connected component so you start with
just the vertices of your graph and you
can start slowly adding ideals of
increasing norms maybe first you add all
the ideals of norm to and you get
something like this
it's not connected yet maybe you go to
norm three and you get something like
this okay
it becomes connected that was too easy
but we do have a general bounce Eric
buck proved in 1990 that choosing B to
be 12 times the logarithm of the field
squared then you always obtain a
connected graph connect it not
necessarily well connected you don't
know how random walks happen in these
graphs if you just pick this bound it
could be a think about like an enormous
cycle it's connected but it's not well
connected if you do a random walk in an
enormous cycle you're probably gonna
take a while before reaching the other
end of the cycle with a simple random
walk okay but we can add more edges we
don't have to stop at this bound and get
better connectivity you study that one
can use a classic object of a graph here
we call the adjacency operator the
adjacency operator it's an operator on
the set of functions from the vertices
of your graph to the complex numbers so
if you're given a function like this
here the vertices of our graph of the
class group so a function from the class
group to the complex numbers the
adjacency operator is defined like this
the adjacency operate to apply to F
evaluated at any point alpha is the
average value of F at all the
predecessors of a find the class [ __ ] so
you take F evaluated at all the
predecessor predecessors of alpha so
alpha times the inverse of you're
generating settlements and you take the
average of that so why do we do this if
F is a probability distribution over the
class group then applying n times the
adjacency operator to F gives you the
corresponding distribution after you've
done n steps of the random walk okay so
now you need to study this operator and
see how it acts acts on this space of
functions from the class group to the
complex numbers and the question in
trying to answer is if you pick any
starting function f does it converge to
something or distribution F does it
converge to uniform and how fast
did you study this question one can
resort to Fourier analysis before you
analysis for finite groups you know that
the characters so characters are group
homomorphism from your starting group to
the multiplicative group of the complex
field these characters they form an
orthogonal basis of the space of
functions from the group to the complex
numbers and what's extremely convenient
is that these characters not only they
form an orthogonal basis but they also
form an orthogonal basis of eigenvectors
for the adjacency operator and this is
very simple just pick your operator
apply it to your character and see
what's happening this is just the
definition here you can split this
multiplication because the characters
are homomorphisms just get that this
doesn't depend on P so you can just
write this to be Lambda Chi so this is
the eigenvalue of the eigenvector ty ok
now it's very easy to see that if you
pick the trivial character which I write
one the corresponding eigenvalue is just
one and if you take any other character
then the eigenvalue is at most one so as
I said the characters form an orthogonal
basis so you can take your this your
your function f you write it as a linear
combination of the characters and you
can apply the adjacency operator to this
it's an linear operator so you can apply
to each component individually since the
trivial eigenvalue is 1 it leaves the
component corresponding to the trivial
character and touched and all the other
components well you just get the
eigenvalues to the power n multiplied by
whatever you had okay so now if you
imagine that all the non-trivial
eigenvalues are strictly less than 1
then this will tend to a one times the
trivial character if F is the unit for
if F is a distribution on the class
group then a one is one over the class
number and a one times one is the
uniform distribution over the class
group so you just need to prove that all
the eigenvalues are strictly less than
one and that's what Jeremy Lin Venkat
ascended in 2005 they prove that you can
choose a bound B and the corresponding
generating set of all prior intervals of
norm at most B such that all the
non-trivial eigenvalues are small enough
the non-trivial eigenvalue is being
small enough means mean that the older
nth power rapidly tends to 0 as n tends
to infinity and therefore the random
walks rapidly tend to uniform okay
how many how many was like is it
gigantic or no it's pulling the no size
you can actually sample uniformly in
there pick a random prime factor it's
pick a random factor you have to be a
little bit careful in your distribution
if you want it to be uniform over all
the primes depending on how it splits at
each step you need to pick one ah okay
for the yes yes I see what you mean yes
you can Mike you don't have to like
build a huge list you just sample yeah
yeah okay so they used this to prove the
random stuff reducibility of the
discrete logarithm problem oh no you had
a question also yeah yeah so I'm I'm
coming to that
so they proved this for the random
surfer disability of the discrete
logarithm by showing that these Cayley
graphs that I show they correspond to I
thought any graphs so graphs where the
vertices are elliptic curves and the
edges represent morphisms between them
and the algebraic norm of the ideals
that you use correspond to the degree of
the isogen ease of the homomorphisms and
the algorithms to compute these I so
Chinese are polynomial time in their
degree so if you want to actually be
able to transfer the discrete logarithm
you need to evaluate these I so Chinese
and therefore you need the degree to be
not too large now let's give it to you
hirato of class groups so I'm going to
start by actually defining it and the
definition is extremely similar to the
definition of a class group so the class
group was just the quotient of the group
of fractional ideals by this group of
principal ideals now principle ideals
you can see them as just direct sum
indexed by all prime ideals of copies of
Z this is a morphism it's just the
factorization of ideal morphism so given
an ideal a
there you can factor it as a product of
prime IT also new right it's
factorization as a vector like this
where each coordinates indexed at P is
the valuation at P of the ideal a so
this is a vector of integers where you
have zeros almost everywhere except at
the places at the Prime's that divide P
that divide a sorry okay so yeah this is
the factorization of a and the class
group you can see it as this direct sum
of copies of Z for shunted by the
factorization of the principle ideals
now an observation is that prime ideals
they are just the circled finite places
of K so I'm not going to go into details
of what places are but essentially a
place of a number field is a way to
define an absolute value in your number
field and you have two kinds of places
the finite places which are precisely
the prime ideals in your face in your in
your number field and another family of
infinite places which are the
essentially the embeddings of your field
into the complex numbers essentially
because you're going to want to work up
to conjugation so an embedding of your
fields into the complex numbers of your
conjugation we call these the infinite
places so it's not probably immediately
obvious how these embeddings relate to
prime ideals but that's and you will
need to guarantee details of what places
exactly are where we can still use these
definitions to define the Oracle of
class group so again the class group is
this quotient and we can extend this sum
with a part that takes into account the
infinite places so here it was the sum
of copy
of Z over all the finite places the
prime ideals now you take the same thing
but you add copies of the real numbers
indexed by the infinite places new yeah
sorry what was that
you don't need you don't need unique you
have unique factorizations of ideals
that's all you need
yes now to define the class group you
needed a notion of principle ideal and
the principal ideals were exactly the
image of the multiplicative group of
your field into this direct sum that
sends an element X to the factorization
of the idea all generated by X yeah and
the class group is just the kernel of
this map so the range quotient it by the
image now on the side of divisors you
also need a notion of principal divisor
and you can define this in a very
similar way as the image of K star of
some morphism so you can take an element
in K star X and send it into this direct
sum by first taking well exactly the
same thing as you had here so the prime
factorization of the ideal generated by
X and adding this quantity here which
some of you might recognize as the
logarithmic embedding
and now you can define the Picard group
in the same way as the crew Colonel of
this map so this direct sum cushion
today the image of K star we are summing
over over the infinite places so the
embeddings of the field into the complex
numbers up to conjugacy yes so that's
the Picard group it's not yet the Oracle
of class group the core group has a
so-called degree zero part Leo told you
it corresponds to rescaling everything
so that everything has norm one and
that's why you have a zero because the
log of one is zero and that is what we
call the Oracle of class group that is
what we call the Oracle of classroom
because depending on which article
you're reading sometimes this is also
the Oracle of this group and it relates
very simply to the Picard group so the
Picard group is the direct product of
this degree zero part by R this is just
the rescaling part what's very
convenient is that this degree zero part
is a is compact whereas this is not now
here's a nice exact sequence here you
have the Picard the degree zero of the
pick R group dismorphism to the class
group is just a morphism that forgets
about all these infinite places so if
you have an element in there you can
just forget about these components and
you fall into exactly the class group
and this is this morphism it was a
surjective morphism you can reach
everything in the class group like this
is of course not an isomorphism because
this is infinite and this is not it has
a kernel and the kernel is this T here
and this T is the torus so the class
group it's a finite group it's in some
sense the discrete part of what's
happening in the Picard group in the
Oracle of transcripts sorry this T is
the unit torus it's somehow the
continuous part it's infinite but it's
compact and it's connected
and the Picard group sits in the middle
it's a bunch of copies of this Taurus
essentially you pick every point in the
class group and you replace it by a
Taurus and you get the Picard group so
from this exact sequence you do get this
idea that the Picard group is the direct
product of the skies book by the Taurus
but that's only true topologically as
Leo said it algebraically well it's
almost a direct product but not quite
all you can say is you have an exact
sequence like this now I ready to do
discrete random walks so let's do
something that's extremely similar to
what we did in class groups say you
start somewhere in the Picard Roop so
you sit somewhere in one of these store
tour eyes that's all right you can try
and start doing the same thing let s be
we the set of all prime ideals of norms
smaller than B now prime ideals there
are not elements in the Picard group
what you could do is look at their class
and then you would get something in the
class group but you don't get quite
something in the Picard group you need
to choose representatives for them in
the Picard group so if you pick a prime
I do P in SB you can look at its class
it would be for instance this point and
you need to choose a representative of
this class in the Picard group namely a
pre-image
under this morphism so you do this and
you call it D of P this is a canonical
way to do this and then once you have
that your random walk is just the same
as we did for class group so you start
somewhere and you multiply by random D
of peas for P taken from this generating
set yeah so this is this corresponds to
the specification ropewalk that Leo
talked about
yeah question I think it doesn't
strongly matter your choices should be
compatible with each other you mean
which pre-med we pick could we pick this
one instead of this one as long as it's
in the same Taurus you could do
different choices and it would work no
no so we choose to do it in a very
canonical way I'm not sure exactly what
would happen if we don't but I think it
would be the same yeah so we can study
that these discrete walks using
something very similar to the adjacency
operator called the Hecker operator it's
pretty much the same thing except you're
right stuff additively instead of
multiplicatively and you work with Bakar
groups or arackliffe class groups
instead of class groups so the Hecker
operator is an operator from the space
of functions on the space of functions
of your EPPICard group it takes as input
a function f from the Picard group to
the complex numbers so exactly the same
situation as previously and is defined
as follows so for any element a in the
pick our group applying the hakko
operator and F evaluating it at alpha is
just taking the average value of F at
all the predecessors of alpha so this
time the predecessors of alpha they are
not alpha divided by the class of P they
are alpha minus the chosen
representative of people
and now the question we're trying to
answer is does applying n times the
second operator to a function f converge
to uniform for any initial F and how
fast you're not not yet
the continuous suspect will come from
your choice of F if F is say a discrete
function something that's zero
everywhere except at a few points then
you cannot hope for this you can reach
something uniform so we can try to do
exactly the same thing will you have
some free a theory for Picard groups
they are still they are compact groups
the commutative groups even and the
space of all characters which are also
defined in the same way the
homomorphisms from the group to the
multiplicative group of the of the other
complex numbers they form an orthogonal
basis of the space of functions of the
world and they are also eigen vectors
for the Hecky operator just like the
characters who are eigen vectors for the
AJ since the operator the proof is
exactly the same and you get something
like that with eigen values that are
exactly the same except there's a type
of here it shouldn't be the class of D
but D of P the chosen representative now
we still have that the eigenvalue
associated to the trivial character is 1
and all the other other eigen values are
at most 1 and we can ask the same
question we decompose F as a character
sum and we can apply the Hecker operator
n time so this should be an H and you
get this decomposition and if all the
non-trivial eigen values are
sufficiently smaller than 1 then this
will tend to the uniform distribution as
n grows yes
yes you do yeah quite yes so let's be a
little bit more careful and see what saw
the precise statements so we can prove
assuming the extend agreement hypothesis
for Hecker characters that the following
holds there is a bound B so B is the
bound on all the norms of Prime ideals
you consider such that for any
non-trivial character the eigenvalue is
at most this quantity so what do we have
in this quantity we have in the
numerator some logarithmic value some
some logarithmic quantity and B and in
the denominator some square root of B so
in be the denominator grow is much
faster so it seems you can always choose
B to be such that the denominator is
much larger than the numerator and
you're going to have something that's
very much smaller than one except you
have this quantity here also in the
numerator which is it's called the
infinite part of the analytic conductor
of the character you can think about it
essentially of the as the frequency of
the character how fast does the
character oscillates so this bound for
characters that have a very high
frequency will not be so good it won't
tell you much it it might even be I mean
the bound might be larger than one which
you know is impossible for I gain values
so this is a void bound when the the
analytic conductor is too large okay but
we still have something the eigenvalues
are small for all the non trivial
characters as long as the frequency is
not too high so applying your random
walk will quickly annihilate all the
components that come from small
frequency characters now what do we do
with high frequency characters that's
where we need the continuous part of the
random walk you add a small continuous
random walk
you annihilate the high frequencies for
that you use a Gaussian with a chosen
standard deviation s they are going to
need to see how big big most s be for
the high frequencies to be annihilated
so once we take this into account we get
the final result pick any standard
deviation s for your discrete part of
the random walk and any epsilon then
there is a bound be on the norms of the
ideals are going to have to consider
this bound is polynomial in all these
quantities such that for any random walk
where the discrete part has a length at
least this quantity then the end point
of the random walk so the discrete
random walk plus the continuous random
walk is at statistical distance at most
Epsilon from the uniform distribution
yes sorry Delta is the discriminant of
the field so that's the theorem we can
prove using these are.this
Fourier analysis and that concludes my
talk any questions say what D D this D P
okay here you want to choose how you're
going to take steps for your random walk
and a step in the random walk is
multiplying by something chosen from a
finite set
that's the discrete random walk so I
need to choose this finite set the so
called generating set in the in the
first setting so we do this by picking
all the prime ideals of norm at most B
but picking just prime ideals don't give
you canonically a point on these objects
they only give you canonically a point
in the class group so that would be for
instance this point now you need to make
a choice for a pre-image of that and
this is DP so ya the inverse of the
point would be the whole torus and you
have to make a choice and say I want
that particular point on the torus
they all mentioned something but how do
you pray mattress this is Taurus
something you know you could not out by
something unit yeah so it's a you
considered the logarithmic embedding
which goes to R to the power of the
number Breeland buildings plus the
number of complex in meetings -1 and the
logarithmic embedding of your maximal
order is a lattice in there and this
torus is the quotient of your space by
the lattice yes yes yes exactly
yeah yes
I didn't get that
the difference between D P and P D P is
not a prime ideal it's
no absent part is how to find my path
than I do and the infinite is some
vector and the infinite dimension is an
ideal the same classic here the finite
part first the infinite part corresponds
to Union to the unit that's your
question
yeah well it's this part corresponds to
the the unit torus that you see it's not
the units it's the the ambient space
coefficient it by the lattice the
logarithmic units
so the questions is by where do i why am
i defining that with the log units yes
yeah
yes what we called SP is is roughly B
over log B the size of this is what I
call SB is yeah so does the Riemann
hypothesis part comes from the fact that
the error term of this assumption is so
the Riemann hypothesis comes from the
estimation of the character soms so the
yes so the eigenvalues that we get are
of this form so we get character sums
and then assuming the Riemann hypothesis
for the heck ul functions you get an
estimation of this up to an error and
the precision of this error relies on
the dependence cuz this step on the
random walk is not is it merely
specifying about this prime ideal or
something additional is it the step on
the random walk yes is it merely just
versifying the ideal by the prime ideal
that you've selected or is there
something more going on corresponding to
the the infinite places in just one step
it's just the sparsa fication yes
the choice of the of D of P where you
have to kind of just choose some
infinite some values yeah I see what you
mean yeah there's nothing work it's just
a way to analyze the thing I mean the
you know since the work is happening
without this right happening it's really
you just an arbitrary choice to think
about it the discrete walk in the KB
graph of the classroom this was already
known about your prior work you have the
feeling that there's like a dozen we'd
walk in there the continuous walking so
could we say like this is maybe more of
a result on the continuous walk I could
this be refer it like you know I guess
you can did you yes yes I guess you
wouldn't get something good if you were
doing the random walks on the torus
independently and then trying to combine
that with the previous results and
random walks on the class group yeah
[Applause]